All right, it is time for "Drew's News,"
your daily scream into the good news pillow.
Oh, how have we all been there?
(Ross laughs) And with me at the desk is a man
I could scream all day long to,
it's Ross Matthews.
Well, that's right, hi everybody!
(audience cheers and applauds)
Hi!
Hi Drew.
Well, it's time for some headlines, Rossy, let her rip.
All right, and first up, Drew, you know,
we all know that you are an icon, whether you say it or not.
No, I am not!
Yes, you are!
No, no!
(audience cheers and applauds)
Drew!
Anyone who thinks they are, not my cup tea, but go on.
Thank you though, thank you.
You're welcome, and for many, many reasons.
One of them is the terrifying way that you died
in the opening of "Scream."
Right, guys, right?
(audience cheers and applauds)
Iconic.
That was fun, that was fun.
That was fun to do.
Well, we all agree with that, and so does Kristen Stewart.
"People" reports Kristen recently revealed
that for "Scream 4," they asked her to die
in the first few minutes of the film,
and you know what she told them?
She was like, no, I'm not doing it, I can't do Drew,
I can't touch that.
This is a true story, they wanted to sort of do an homage
to your character, Casey, in "Scream 4,"
and she turned it down because she was like,
no I could never do it like Drew did it.
Look, she's hearing this for the first time!
(audience laughs and claps)
I'm also such an uber fan of hers.
I know.
Like,
I can't even believe she knows I'm alive,
and then like,
(audience laughs)
I, oh my gosh, oh.
Yeah.
I mean.
(audience laughs)
Okay, Kristen Stewart, I could never be Bella,
I could never be Diana.
(Ross laughs)
I could never be you in anything that you ever do.
I am so enamored with you,
and I have been for so long, I'm so,
I'm thrilled that I have a Kristen Stewart
stamp of approval on anything I've ever done in my life.
Thank you.
Yes, she loves you!
Oh my God, I love her so much!
I know, do you know, she also turned down the lead role
in "The Ross Matthews Story" for the same reason.
She was like, I can't do that.
(audience laughs)
I can't, I won't, I won't, he does it too well.
(Drew laughing)
(Ross laughs)
I really kinda wanna see that movie.
That was really stupid.
I know, I'd watch it, I would!
Well.
I smell Oscar.
Funny enough, our story next is a casting news story.
Sony is following up their mega smash hit "Spider-Man"
with a female spider hero movie,
we've talked about it on this show,
'cause our friend, Dakota Johnson,
will be not and other than "Madame Web,"
but it gets even crazier.
"Deadline" reports, another incredible actress
will be joining her.
Ladies and gentlemen, Sydney Sweeney will be joining her.
And when I mean Sydney Sweeney,
I mean that's Sydney Sweeney.
Oh, cover os "Cosmo."
(Drew mmhmms)
(Ross mmhmms)
I mean, she's hot off "Euphoria,"
she is scene stealing in "White Lotus."
"White Lotus," yeah.
She's been on the show, and she was so nice,
and so lovely.
(mmhmms) And she's having such a moment,
you know that show that you love,
and that character you love?
It's her, it's her!
(audience laughs)
And she's, it's so great to see an actress like
come into her moment,
and then get that spotlight kinda role.
And also, like, let's face it, at the box office,
the way the world works now with streaming,
habits, economics, it's usually the Marvel movies
that are making the money.
So, to see these two extraordinary women in a Marvel movie,
I'm like, yes, thank you so much.
I'm so into this movie!
(audience applauding)
Yeah, me too.
(upbeat rock music)
♪ Oh, oh ♪